for climate change which policies work
which don't
which are when we look at this formula
of one dollar in forty five dollars out
for climate change what dollar in what
policies for dollar in and and dollar
out are good and which are not yep so so
we actually did a a whole project back
in 2009 when when the The Whole World
Circus was coming to Copenhagen and we
were going to save the world there uh we
brought together about 50 climate
economists and three Noble alerts to
look at where can you spend a dollar and
do the most good for climate and what
they found was a lot of these things as
we've been talking about before that
that basically investing in in the
current sort of technology that we're
trying very hard is at best at pretty
dicey outcome uh much of it's probably
less than a dollar back in the dollar uh
there's some uh investments in on
adaptation for instance that's pretty
good but it's you know sort of two three
dollars back in the dollar
the obvious thing is that you built a
dike for a sea level rise or that you
make people uh you get some apps that
people know that there's a hurricane
coming or that you know so you can adapt
infrastructure right yeah the physical
and the digital infrastructure the point
is that people are really good at doing
this already because they have a strong
incentive to do it so the extra thing
that governments can do outside is
somewhat good but it's not amazing or
anything what we found by far the best
uh investment in the long run was on
investment in Innovation so and and I
think this also sort of corresponds with
what we would think in general uh if we
could innovate so you know for instance
Bill Gates is arguing we should have
fourth generation Nuclear So the next uh
the more advanced than what we currently
have in third generation nuclear which
would be uh industrial scale process
you'd just be building these you know uh
modular nuclear power plants they would
be instead of being these artwork that
we design once for every different plant
which is one of the reasons why they're
so expensive they would just be mass
produced and you'd have one you know uh
uh they all be recognized in one go so
be much cheaper they would also be
passively safe so uh if if all the power
goes they'll shut down rather than go
boom uh so that's that's another very
good thing and then they'll also uh be
very hard to transform into nuclear uh
weapons so you can actually imagine them
being out in a lot of different places
where we'd perhaps be a little worried
about having you know plutonium lying
around now this is all still being
worked out but imagine if that actually
comes out and again remember the other
three generations they were we were also
told they'll be incredibly safe and
it'll be incredibly cheap and it didn't
turn out that way so let's let's wait
but it could be
and so the argument is invest in these
ideas for instance fourth generation
nuclear and if first generation nuclear
becomes cheaper than fossil fuels we're
done everyone will just switch not just
Rich well-meaning Americans or Europeans
but also the Chinese the Indians
everybody in Africa the rest is uh
Indian subcontinent that's how you fix
these issues right so the idea here is
to say instead of thinking that we can
sort of push people to do stuff they
really don't want to do which is
basically saying let's let's use more of
the uh you know the solar and wind that
you would otherwise have invested in
force people to buy an electric car by
giving huge subsidies because otherwise
they're clearly not all that interested
in buying it and so on then get the
Innovation such that they become cheaper
than fossil fuels and everyone will
switch this is how we've solved problems
in the past if you think in in Los
Angeles in the 1950s was hugely polluted
place mostly because of cars this sort
of standard climate approach today would
be to tell everyone in Los Angeles I'm
sorry could you just walk instead and of
course that just doesn't work that
doesn't pay off you never get you know
politicians voted in office or at least
staying in office if you make that kind
of policy what did solve the problem was
the innovation of the catalytic
converter you basically get those little
Gizmo and it cost equal a hundred
dollars and you put it on your tailpipe
and then you can drive around basically
almost not pollute and that that's how
you fix the air pollution in Los Angeles
basically we've solved all problems in
humanity all big difficult problems with
Innovation we haven't solved it by
telling everyone I'm sorry could you be
a little less comfortable and a little
more cold and a little poorer and
believing that that can go on for you
know decades and and while it possibly
Works in some pockets of the US and I I
think actually in large parts of Europe
at least it used to uh the this uh the
the war in Ukraine is definitely sort of
changing that whole perspective but yeah
there's a willingness to say we're gonna
you know suffer a little bit then we'll
fix this problem but the point is we're
going to be willing to suffer a little
and so fix a tiny bit of the climate
problem instead of actually focusing on
Innovation so what we found was if you
spend a dollar on Innovation you will
probably avoid about 11 of climate
damage in the long run which is a great
investment and the terrible thing is
we have not been doing this so because
everybody is focused on saying we need
the solution within the next 12 years it
means you're not thinking about the
Innovation we're actually spending less
money not more money on uh on Innovation
globally so everyone is frequency and
reducing carbon emission versus
innovating on Alternate energy you're
basically focusing on putting the
existing solar panels or wind turbines
which are either you know just about
inefficient or inefficient instead of
making the Next Generation or it's more
likely the 10th Generation after that
that comes with lots of you know a
battery backup power or you know a
fourth generation nuclear or you know
Craig Venter has this great idea Craig
venzo the guy who cracked the human
genome back in 2000 he has this idea of
growing algae out on the ocean surface
these algae they'd be genetically
modified and they would basically soak
up sunlight and CO2 and produce oil then
we could basically just grow our own
Saudi Arabia on the ocean surface and
we'd Harvest it we'd keep our entire
fossil fuel economy but it'd not be Net
Zero because we just soaked up the CO2
out there one dollar invested in the
portfolio of different ideas gives you
eleven dollars yeah I I first wrote
about that in the New York Times it was
one of my actual page one stories
um in 2006 it was declining r d in
energy at a time of global warming and
the Baseline is so low for this that
it's a it's a supermarket we were
in during the there was during the
energy crisis the 70s the first energy
crisis in the 70s before the current one
um
are
annual spending the United States and
constant dollars on R D research and
development for energy
was about five billion dollars and then
it just dribbled away
since then and recently now there's a
big burst of new money coming through
these new bills that got passed but what
I was told over and over again by people
in that Arena
is you can't just have these little
bubbles of investment you don't get
young people
away from thinking about Wall Street for
jobs towards thinking about energy
Innovation if there isn't like a future
there and a lot of the in the United
States and Europe the presumption was
the wage that future was taxing
carbon
you'd make that so punitive that the
your basically the leveling even in the
landscape for cleaner stuff that's more
expensive that's a that has failed
completely
they're little examples in Europe where
it's working
and what's happened now is well the
United States this big chunk of money
is designed to take us over a Finish
Line
that was started with not just
Innovation but with the production
efficiency too this is one thing I got
wrong I think a little bit my reporting
I was so fixated on the Innovation part
just because I love science too I saw
this untapped possibility
that others were saying no no production
efficiency the more people are producing
batteries the cheaper they'll get this
is Elon musk's uh you know path and many
others
and it really is both so when you were
talking about purchasing power for
governments for example
that can stimulate production
capacity for batteries or whatever the
good thing is and take you down faster
and it's all about getting that margin
of the new thing out competing the old
and it's not just Innovation it has so
many parts of the pipeline that need to
be nurtured so so
and and the other thing is relative cost
the United States when I was writing
about this in 2006
our budget for DARPA the advanced
research project Agency for for the
defense department
for just for science for was 80 billion
a year
for health from for medical Frontier
research on cancers of 40 billion energy
was two or three
so we weren't taking this remotely
seriously so now that if we get that up
to me to me there's like this level
you know we're taking something
seriously when it's like in the tens of
billions for r d it's not that r d will
solve the problem but are but it's a
proxy for what we really care about We
Care a shitload about defense
what's the defense budget in the United
States now like 800 billion it's some
insane number who's counting when you're
having fun yeah yeah yeah and so um
Innovation is not just like for the
better
you know camera the better solar panel
the better battery social Innovation
actually matters hugely like the guy in
nairobia mentioned
with a company doing micro payment gas
to get people off charcoal
we need that as much as this and I
actually I interviewed Bill Bill Gates
uh we had to spend an hour with him in
Seattle
in 2016
um
was when he was rolling out his
breakthrough energy thing I got to spend
it was 45 minutes me and Bill Gates
which was pretty fun but I I brought
this up I said you know because he's all
about the new nuclear thing that will
solve The World's problems and I yes yes
but we also have nuclear science oh he
did oh sure so he's interested in the in
one of those he's investing heavily in
nuclear but he invests in everything you
know he's got a big portfolio
um
but I brought up a guy I met in India
um
who runs a little outfit called Selco
that they do really interesting cool
Village to Village
they're like an energy analyst will come
to your house here in the states and
tell you how to weatherize your house
but they do it at the Village scale
and in a village that has um
where they're Milling wheat he'll put in
a solar-powered wheat wheat Mill
and
you know that's not going to solve The
World's problems but it gives them a way
to control their energy they don't have
to buy something to grind their wheat
and that needs just as much attention as
the the things I really like too the
cool Technologies and and I I thought I
cornered Bill the gates I was like
because he really does focus on these
big wins the big you know like nuclear
that will make Net Zero completely
doable and I said well you know
what about nuclear like New York City
where I was still living at the time or
near and I said it's got a million
buildings
New York City has one million buildings
and in 2013 the Bloomberg government
analyzed they said looking ahead to 2050
75 of the buildings in New York City
that will exist in 2050 already exist
think about these Brave New Futures
right like we're just gonna come in have
these shiny cool passive house cities
and I so I put this to Bill and I said
so
what's how do you do that how do you how
do you retrofit all those boilers many
of which were coal-fired like 20 years
ago
to get a zero energy New York City and I
thought I kind of thought I had him you
know he immediately he kind of sat back
and went well but if you have unlimited
clean power coming into that City it
doesn't really matter
it's a pretty good Bill Gates
impressions
he said oh yeah it's a leaky bucket but
you know pour in zero carbon energies
and it doesn't matter
but I still think we have to figure out
the other part too the that end how do
you how do you innovate at the household
level at the Village level
it's much more of a distributed problem
we used to think the one the one big
change I've had in my own thinking too
is
is from top down to distributed
everything about the climate problem
through the first three decades of my
reporting was that the
the ipcc will come out a new report the
the framework convention the treaty will
get us on board
we'll all behave better this it has this
like top-down you know parent to child
architecture
and everything's I've learned has gone
the other way it's distributed capacity
for improved lives you know kids getting
through school
women not having to spend three hours
collecting firewood and if it means
propane for that household in that
context that's a good thing so stop with
all your yammering about standing all
fossil fuel subsidies and
you know what's in America look like
that has some claim climate safe Energy
Future
find your part in that
don't get disempowered by the scale of
it there's like a thousand things to do
when you start to cut it into pieces so
so it's very different it's not a
top-down thing
you know no one's going to magically
come in and and and that's that's where
I think so I agree that everyone should
try to play their their part and and and
do you know whatever they can uh but I
also think you know just the the sheer
incentives you know what we saw
happening with you know with uh Shale
gas is a great example when Shale gas
becomes so cheap that you just stop
using coal but then you don't really
have to convince you know lots and lots
of people
and it wasn't labeled a climate no it
wasn't a climate thing it was an energy
thing it was totally uh and and and the
point is just you know the power of an
innovation is that you you almost don't
see it anymore it just happens uh and
and I think that's really the only way
we're gonna fix you know these big
problems if you think about you know of
the uh nutrition problem back in the 60s
70s uh we worried a lot about India and
other places uh solution is not worrying
or the solution was not you know us
eating a little bit less and sending it
down to India wherever the solution was
the Green Revolution right it was the
fact that some scientists made ways to
make every seed produce three times as
much so you could grow three times as
much food on an acre and you know that's
what basically made it possible for
India to go from a basket case to what
the world's leading uh rice exporter uh
and and and that's how you do these
things you know you solve these big
problems true Innovation and again I'm
not saying that you know we're actually
arcing our carbon tax is a smart thing
to do you know that's what any Economist
would tell you to do but it also turns
out that it's partly it's not going to
solve most of the problem and it's
incredibly politically hard to do so it
may also just be the wrong sort of tree
to bark up against you know if you can
do it please do uh but this is not the
main thing that's going to solve climate
the the main thing is that we get these
innovations that basically make green
energy so cheap everyone will just want